how surreal was it stepping back
on that stage after being away for so
long
completely surreal like there's no way
to even articulate like i knew it would
be odd and
um but it was so emotional and so big
and so beyond because i think also
because when's the last time you've ever
gone back to a job that you started 18
years ago that you left then you know
what i'm saying you're like there's no
infrastructure like there's no construct
for it because even like when if you say
oh it's like kind of like going home
you know like to your parents you're
like wait
this is my room okay yeah that's right i
have a
an airplane bed
who do you think it is definitely
someone big
i'm dr addison montgomery
and you must be the group that's been
screwing up the program i was living for
the promo where it shows you going to
the interns and introducing yourself and
saying
you must be the group that's been
screwing up the program and it was a nod
to when you first met meredith right and
you said
oh yeah hi
i'm anderson shepard
[Music]
shepherd
and you must be the woman who's been
screwing my husband it was funny when we
first did that in the zoom table read
too it was very fun i was like okay this
is my first time this is awesome it's
such a yeah it's a total wink a nod
total kitsch moment yeah did you think
that was kind of the perfect way to
reintroduce you to
i did but i was worried about i was very
nervous about like it was odd i was i
said to um krista and i think and you
know the delightful amazingly talented
chandra wilson who plays bayley who also
directs a lot of the episodes now she
directed the episode so it was like old
homeschool week it was just great um and
i felt in such great hands but i said to
her you know it's so weird how you
immediately become an actress again
where you're like wait does my hair look
okay is my that dude okay you just
become this quivering shivering insecure
person so and that moment you just have
to like land it i'm like i hope it
worked so yeah
surprise
i bet you thought you'd seen the last of
me but like the benefit of tv dramas you
went back after 18 years
but really because you left after season
three you hadn't done like a guest
appearance since 2012 so ultimately what
made you say
okay yeah this time
well it's first of all we've been
talking about it for a while like you
know coming back and just having a
little visit and um it's such an iconic
show it was such an important show for
me my my life my career so christopher
enough and i had been talking and trying
to find a time where it was the right
time for grays and story lines and
scheduling and all that
and i
um thought you know what this is the
right time and also the story the the
writing is so great and i i
you know i mentioned this um
before
but i jamie dembo who's a long time
friend of mine wrote this first episode
that i appear in and it was so
great the writing is so good it's so
classic
like i'd say vintage grays it's that you
know fine line and
of making you laugh and cry i think
hopefully and also for the fans i think
in every interview i've ever done in the
last 18 or 10 years or whatever is like
would you ever go back yeah and so guess
what
yes is the answer i'm doing
i did it i think people are going to
really love it i mean i have gotten
really positive feedback from a few
people behind the scenes have seen the
episode and you know are really excited
so oh we are all here for addison's
return honey and just seeing you back is
love on a plate like it does not even
matter did it take you a minute to get
back like with the jargon and all of
that or was it like riding a bike did
you just jump right back um no the
medical medical stuff is always like oh
i got to open up that part of my brain
again and start jamming it in um and
then then it clicked then it clicked um
particularly by the second episode i
really got um because there's more of
this just that classic scene writing of
big scenes too
but this was so
well written the medical medical is
always like okay what hey what i gotta
like yeah all these
different syllables and vowels put
together that i really don't know what
they are but i gotta look like i'm an
expert sure so that took a
a minute but you know they're all really
patient and uh nurse linda linda klein
who's been on the show and
the medical nurse made me of course
still look good and her crew and surgery
scene so
yeah that part was like riding a bike
the hvac system controls the air
filtration in the hospital you'll need
to close her as soon as possible to
prevent injection not stopping tova's
transplant she's been waiting months for
this then find a way to double your
speed find me a set of hands who's
experienced in microvascular anastomosis
of the abdomen
get me meredith gray
so addison and meredith have a very
complicated history um where are they
now and and where what's the state of
their relationship now
well i think that you see it and i can't
talk about it too much because it kind
of unfolds and it's a big reveal in a
way in this episode but i think that you
know addison has always respected her
and i think meredith has always
respected addison's um professional
skills and where they are and i think um
it's one of my favorite scenes is the i
mean you see in the promo you're like
get me that get me dr greg
get me meredith gray so we get to work
together a little bit in this episode i
mean and then there's some there's some
good personal stuff that comes up too
and i think it's really um it will be
very surprising too and very satisfying
to fans and but in a very surprising way
like i
yeah that's all i can say
where they're working together and where
they're having some personal time
together so okay so maybe some wounds
could get healed and or maybe some
deeper ones could
emerge
now we'll see how time will tell we'll
see thursday night thursday night
so is addison single no she's still
she's still married to jake yeah okay so
no romance or one whale you never we
don't know i mean who knows what she's
capable of okay
how are you gonna be back for i mean is
this gonna be like you give us like that
little yummy taste and then you leave us
again on the floor crumpled up in a ball
or you're going to stick and stay i mean
a little bit i know she's like the like
the classic unavailable mother character
she's like bye i'm here and then gone i
did two episodes and then you know we'll
see what you see we'll see what happens
yeah could they convince you to stay
long-term or longer longish terms oh i
don't know about that i've got um other
commitments right now so i'm you know
and i kind of am halfway around the
world most of the time so yeah
you joined the late in season one and i
wonder at that point in time did you
know yeah we got something really
special here or i mean i'm not sure that
anybody could have imagined how big of a
hit
this show would become i don't think
anybody could imagine how big it would
it would be but i definitely felt like
it was special and it was really
singular and unique and incredible and
i'm and i remember because i came in at
episode 8 which and they'd been shooting
for a while it was one of those things
where
they weren't sure what they kept
changing the title still at different
table reads it was like grey's anatomy
that it was like doctors and it was like
yeah i don't know it was just always
like this different i'm like grey's
anatomy is great that's like so clever
why are you changing the title i came in
you know at episode eight and i was
watching these episodes at crew lodges
like this is great this is like a great
show they called me back to come
be on the show as a serious regular so
yeah well 18 seasons is is you know
unheard of uh in hollywood and it's i
mean it's just amazing and you know i
know you've heard all the speculation
about could this be the last one what
will happen
um
forward
let's just play for a second if this is
the grand finale
how would you like to see these
characters go out and could grace
survive without meredith i don't know
and the answers to any of those
questions i wish i could even i can't
even pontificate it's like
they it's a it's in
the minds of like the great minds of the
writers i mean honestly i don't know how
you keep creating it's like it's grey's
anatomy so i just don't think that you
know it's going to be you know meredith
grey bounces i don't think it's going to
be like and now you know but who knows
you know creative universe really it's
really about yeah anything's possible
and that's the beauty of art anything's
possible